well let's talk about this here uh
multi-tiered justice system with this
story from the Daily Mail green
Jean-Pierre snaps at the press for
asking if the cocaine belonged to Hunter
or the Biden family because uh what was
the latest update that was actually near
The Situation Room in like a in like a
family and like high security area
White House secretary Kareem Jean-Pierre
snapped at a reporter who had asked her
to say once and for all the cocaine
found in the White House did not belong
to a Biden family member I just I love
how it's like a Biden family member
because everybody knows you're not
allowed to say his name you're not the
mainstream the media and all the
reporters they're not allowed to say his
name basically you know there's been
some irresponsible reporting of the
family and so I've got to call that out
here the press secretary said and I have
been very clear I was clear two days ago
when talking was over and over again and
as I was being asked the question as you
know the media Outlets reported this the
Biden family was not here they were not
here they were at Camp David they were
not here Friday they were not here
Saturday they were not here Sunday they
were not even here Monday they came back
on here on Tuesday it's remarkable
because like
Kareem
they weren't there on Friday were they
there on Thursday oh and if they were
could Hunter have dropped his cocaine
then well okay yeah well I I think them
just not being transparent about it or
her not talking to Secret Service or
anything like that to actually have some
decent answers for the reporters I do
love that we're the point where No One
Believes them I know the reporter's just
like come on yeah like come on you know
Hunter Biden's a crackhead what do you
expect is the belief but uh in terms of
jills we have no clue but let's just be
a Biden family member I don't know for
sure and Maybe not maybe some senior
official someone connected but let's
just pause and break down January 6.
bumbling guy walks through doors open
for him by police takes selfie with cops
adheres to The Velvet ropes as he walks
around smiling the police then say
everyone's gotta go and they go okay and
they wave and leave two years in prison
someone at a high level of government
bringing illicit drugs into the White
House ah we can't figure this one out
sorry everybody have a nice day how
about this whoever planted the pipe
bombs can't figure that one out either
yeah multi-chair multi-tiered justice
system I was this is a bit anecdotal but
I watched that video of Hunter on stage
with Jill and Joe from the July 4th
celebration where hunters look all he
looks all like tweaking right pretty
hard for like a couple seconds and then
he goes behind Jill and I'm watching
Joe's maybe we can pull this video up
watch Joe he smiles real tense like
and Jill looks so just mortified right
when Hunter's behind her looks like he's
snorting coke off his wrist or something
or out of a vial and Joe like when his
arm goes up is when Joe goes like like
really awkward smile and Jill gets real
annoyed like oh God she can't stand that
guy hunter it's just so obvious I think
she's said it plaintively in the past
that she I don't know to be honest I
don't have the documentation here but do
you guys remember that South Park
episode that's good I think it was from
the 2008 election with McCain and Obama
probably and it's like the whole purpose
of running for president was it was a
diamond Heist to like race oh yeah yeah
and they're like boom baby it's like yes
I think it'd just be a really great
short film where it's like the Biden
family I don't like you make a show
people think it's like Veep but Veep is
silly but the Biden family is more like
degenerate you know like um what's that
what's that one show about House of
Cards no the family in Chicago that are
like Shameless Shameless yeah yeah just
like a bunch of degenerates and yes
that's like yeah you call it Shameless I
I didn't see that one but South Park's
been doing a pretty good job uh
especially on the Tran stuff they did a
pretty good job
man right yes right competing with the
Simpsons on some of this stuff well The
Simpsons are woke
uh I meant predict like for the
predicting of like the future well no I
just mean like relations The Simpsons
predicting things ended 20 years ago
right you know South Park still like
like five years ahead of the curve right
it's crazy are they predicting it or are
they giving it a green light I don't
think they're giving it a green light no
I think I think what happens with uh uh
you know if you watch a show like Black
Mirror not so much this latest season
because it's more of a horror series at
this point than a Sci-Fi series but it's
just a thought experiment it's a it's a
hypothetical like what happens if x
continues so when we're looking at
government like you just ask yourself a
logical question if Hunter Biden is a
crackhead I'm sure a lot of people could
have easily predicted we'll eventually
find drugs in the White House hey it
happened now we're supposed to believe
it was not Hunter he's the notorious
famous drug user so look maybe maybe
it's only a five percent chance it was
Hunter he still has the the dominant
plurality of probability The Narrative
is is already set either way like it
doesn't really matter if Hunter did have
it or not because it's not likely that
there's going to be any kind of
significant investigation the people on
the right have already made up their
mind that it was Hunter they're gonna
say it was Hunter and meme the hell out
of it even if it kind of sucks on him at
this point because he's getting blamed
for it anyway right I mean he's already
but he look there's there's video of him
smoking crack on his way to Las Vegas
driving 100 no no was it the same one
where he was driving 172 miles he was I
mean I heard the crack in the car was
different than the driving 107. it
doesn't matter but the point the point
that I'm making is it doesn't matter
because he was going to Vegas to bang
hookers he definitely smokes a bunch of
crack he's definitely had Coke so like
was it his what is it not he was who
cares he definitely bangs hookers smokes
crack and drops
that is such a good point though I think
most of the American people probably
just draw that conclusion anyways it
doesn't matter what the truth is at this
point they just say okay well uh cocaine
yeah there you go he still does all that
right it just draws attention to that
yeah no here's the thing about Hunter
buying like we are all people who uh try
to be to a certain degree virtuous and
we're like how dare he drive at such a
high rate smoking crack but there are
people who do nothing but party and club
and they're like whoa like he's cool I
don't want people to think that I'm
saying that I'm virtuous
ability I have I've been in a band for
too long I have a history no if you go
to like the average person at a club on
a Friday or Saturday night and you're
like let me tell you something about
this guy who drives like 170 miles an
hour while smoking crack and banging
hookers they're gonna be like damn like
who's this guy sounds like he can party
it's like the president's son they're
gonna go wow you're really going 170 was
that well I think I don't know like I
think it was in the in the fight does it
matter if it's 140 was he really coming
he was going that fast I mean the point
is like 30 miles an hour does it really
matter yeah no unless you're up over 98
I mean you're pretty much well if you're
over 120 I think one of the most extreme
differences is watching how the media
reported on Trump's children and how
intense I mean there there was an
article every single day about this with
Hunter you don't really I mean you don't
say his name dude they're even saying a
a Biden family member it's like like
who's it going to be Jill right you know
we know what you're saying yeah but
nobody's saying his name nobody talks
about him yeah here's a photo booger
sugar August 1st 2018 purports to show
Hunter Biden feeding to a Las Vegas
so is this video taken by him too I
guess because I tell you what NBC you're
right maybe it's not his cocaine in the
White House all the other stuff but no
but to be fair for even this like it's a
photo from his laptop most likely was
him but who knows maybe it was uh Devin
Archer or somebody somebody you worked
with maybe it was Joe himself you know
they shared phone numbers or emails or
something like that and you know look
there's a lot of Highways out there
heading to Vegas where there's nothing
around and there's no speed limit so
technically he might not be actually
breaking the law because it goes by like
are you driving unsafe we know he had
cracked no he's definitely breaking the
law I'll stop with that one
Hunter's 2021 Memoir beautiful things he
admitted to crashing a Buick Verano
while speeding through Palm Springs
during another drug Bender in October
2016. wait man don't speak in the book
Hunter wrote that he was high for 12
consecutive days before entering an
Arizona rehab
what the hell
it's unfortunate seeing people struggle
with addiction and all that stuff but
also at the same time you have the Biden
family that basically I mean if anything
they can pull this off I would say worse
than let's say this was the case for
Trump or something I mean they sell
themselves as the adults are back in
charge they're all responsible good uh
everybody says how good of a parent he
is you know who Hunter Biden uh uh Joe
Biden you know they sell him like this
good good good guy yeah
um that's just Marketing in the caller
Philly Joe whatever right just one of
the boys Joe Scranton right and this is
just uh hairy legs it's not it's not a
good look I got compassion for the drug
addict right I often do but at the same
time if my military commander has a drug
problem I want to take him out of power
I want somebody else in command if the
military commander has a son with a drug
problem and brings them around to the
military command spot which is the White
House that's a big problem for me or get
some really really high paying jobs as
well in prestigious positions or that
drug addicted son is sending text
messages saying you better do it or else
I'm going to tell my dad is going to
hold it he's sitting right next to me
right now exactly exactly can we make a
show like can someone finance a Game of
Thrones style show called The bidens
because it would be a great TV show I
mean you could probably get if if you
didn't actually call it the bidens you
might be able to get something that's
true
we've got a show you know our drama
cells show pitch okay I'm talking like
two million dollars per episode budget
with big deal HBO I hope you're
listening it's about a uh political
family
they cheat in an election to win
by having you know people go in late
hours and swap out boxes and stuff like
that then once they get in they start
doing Shady business deals to enrich
themselves think about it's Game of
Thrones the modern era it writes itself
and answers dragons
that's the name of the show chasing the
dragon just literally shot for shot
remake Game of Thrones but in a modern
context and the dragons would just be
like warships and stuff dragons just a
TENS Birds
chasing the dragons and it's a war movie
kind of but it's about a corrupt
political establishment that's entangled
in some crazy war and drones that get
hacked that end up getting turned around
on the Homeland or something that'd be
wild and then what you got to do is you
got to have like the guy who becomes
president is this like decrepit
degenerate you know Alzheimer's
out of shape and disgusting and then his
rival who gets cheated has to be this
like tall chiseled and muscular blonde
man who sells real estate
that's right it's ice cream for people
every every season they find a way to
make the you know the leader just
collapse on the ground in some creative
way as well
yes it's every season like he's on one
of those like floors if he's gonna be in
the next season but he is I want to play
the Cliffhanger the hunter Biden
character in that I think I could pull
it off it'd be like Jared Leto in in
whatever movies he does where he's like
all strung out or Memento I think that
movie was pretty good yeah are you
looking to do like method acts yeah
so let's strung thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8 pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time